the 2017 big-screen adaptation of
Stephen King's novel it is a major
success with critics and audiences due
in no small part to the way the movie
incorporates the books most essential
elements while sidestepping some of its
more controversial or uncomfortable
moments these are the most disturbing
scenes from its that were left behind
during the long journey to theaters
Patrick Hawks theatres cruelest act in
the movie patrick hochstätter is hardly
a central figure to the story he's
clearly a jerk but not nearly as
terrible as he was in the novel Patrick
isn't exceptionally disturbed young man
in the book and a few scenes to show
that more than when he suffocates his
baby brother in his crib why was this
cut for the movie maybe to save time and
narrow the narrative focus or maybe the
filmmakers just had no interest in
getting quite that dark Patrick's deaf
scene in the 2017 movie Patrick's deaf
scene is entirely different than the way
it goes down in the novel he dies in the
barren sewer drain while stalking the
losers on paper however Patrick's death
is a little more disturbing after he and
Henry find themselves alone in the woods
Patrick makes a sexual advance on Henry
who ends up leaving eventually left
alone Patrick is attacked by it in the
form of swarming bugs a death that
matches his worst nightmare
and we Bauer's home life in the movie
Henry Bowers father is portrayed as an
alcoholic police officer who has no
qualms about accosting his son in front
of his friends but aside from the gun
scene his cruelty is mostly hinted at in
the book however Henry's home life is a
lot more messed up butch Bowers as a
Marine veteran who's developed psychosis
and is verbally and physically abusive
to his family including Henry
the only thing Henry seems to be able to
do right by his father is act upon their
shared racism against the Hanlon family
the town plays the 2017 its movie
handles Mike's history in very obscure
terms we're told his parents died in a
gruesome house fire and that had seen
them burn which is why he's so haunted
by the image of burnt hands reaching out
from the meat stores alley entrance he
shown us a bearer of some bad news about
the town's history courtesy of his
grandfather but for the most part the
role
the resident historian of the group has
given to Ben Hanscom instead the book
goes into a lot more detail about Mike's
pain the notorious town fire reference
and the movie took place a club called
the black spots and his dad was there
the night it was burned down it's also
Mike's dad who encourages him to study
the town sinister history which is how
he becomes a librarian and the only one
to stay in Derry after the rest of the
losers Club leaves the death of Eddie
Corcoran not only is Eddie Corcoran
story one of the most tragic subplots in
the book but he didn't even make it into
the movie a student at the same school
as the losers
Eddie stepfather kills his little
brother with a hammer which leaves Eddie
on the run for his life he ends up in
the Barrens where he encounters it which
takes the form of his recently deceased
little brother before turning into a
Gillman and decapitating Eddie
[Music]
Eddie's first encounter
Eddie Casper axe first encounter with it
in the movie is relatively similar to
the novel he passes by the creepy house
on the bolt streets and runs into a
leper
which is a combination of his worst fear
of severe and contagious illnesses in
the book however the scenes a little
more adult many readers thought Eddie's
mother also stunted his emotional and
sexual maturity by demanding that all
his affection be reserved for her the
leper doesn't make fun of his medication
instead he offers to perform sexual
favors in exchange for cash suggesting
that Eddie's been taught to fear his
sexuality most likely because of
communicable diseases that's a little
too happy to explore in a single scene
so it's easy to understand the white was
ditched the goon squad Henry Bowers is
shown tumbling down the well to his
possible death in the 2017 movie and
aside from Patrick the rest of his bully
crude seems to get out of the movie
without getting hurt in the book however
they're all caught by it in the sewers
after chasing the losers
Vica gets his head torn off by the
creature who appears as Frankenstein's
monster and belch as his face ripped in
half after trying to defend Henry so
yeah it's all a lot more graphic in the
book the ritual of Judd the ending of it
has certainly simplified things when it
came to the loser's first banishment of
the beast
once they rescued Beverly from a
floating comatose state they are
fearless against the creature after they
managed to injure it by striking its
head the monster slinks into the well
and the killing stopped for now in the
book however there's a lot more to it a
whole lot billed Umbra uses an ancient
technique called the ritual of Judd
which takes him into the macro verse
where he encounters the universe his
creator a giant turtle named Mattern the
turtle informs him that he can only
defeat it in a battle of wills and bill
weakens it enough but the losers can
make a physical attack it's a much more
supernatural and celestial process than
what we see on screen and if it is any
indication the forthcoming sequel may
also bypass this bonkers aspect of the
story altogether the smoke hole the
movie also completely omitted a book
scene that would probably be regarded as
insensitive on film in the
Sene bill uses a Native American smoke
hole ritual in an effort to find out
more about the demon terrorizing Gary
bill and Ritchie end up staying in the
hotbox long enough to realize that it is
an evil force that's sucking the
lifeblood out of the town it's a
realization that works just as well with
a rudimentary history lesson but it's a
clear example of the movie avoiding the
necessary controversy which is pretty
interesting since it's still a movie
about kids battling a child eating
monster of course as controversial as
that would have been it's nothing
compared to the sewer escape this is
probably the most infamous scene that
never made it from the book to the
screen in any version in the movie the
losers have no trouble exiting the sewer
system after their battle with it in the
book however they find that they can't
remember the way out the solution at
PEVs own suggestion or six of the boys
have sex with Beverly Marsh in quick
succession so they can be united again
and find their way back to the Barrens
there's been a lot of debate about the
scene from the book whether this is
belittling abusive or even empowering
for Beverly
but even Stephen King himself has since
walked back on his value to the story I
wasn't really thinking of the sexual
aspect of it the book dealt with
childhood and adulthood intuitively the
losers knew they had to be together
again the sexual acts connected
childhood and adulthood it's another
version of the glass tunnel that
connects the children's library and the
adult library times have changed since I
wrote that scene and there is now more
sensitivity to those issues like the
1990 TV miniseries 2017 zr2 basically
ignores that part of the plot which
saves the filmmakers a lot of trouble
bringing the problematic scene to life
not to mention saving a lot of
moviegoers from a pretty awkward
conversation once they got home thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]